is this for the oklahoma job the week 14
playoff picture oh yay hey i'm lacey's
and lindy the main star of the bucks
elisha you scared brady later uh you're
four hours we're trying to make a
perfect picture okay but no one's good
enough oh
um
i blame detroit still mccarthy what's
your deal we're all vaccinated in some
way
there ain't no shadow coach look alive
[Music]
let's get the good afc teams in i'm too
strong for my crutches we realized we
needed a manning cast the park i could
be a contender i don't believe you i'm
the three seed
i could be a contender i could be a
contender hey kid i could be a contender
we'll see if the makeup folks can get
rid of the whole you know bengals thing
where's debo he's supposed to play two
roles time for the playoff picture
taylor's version sorry i was in the
wrong studio we're like a lifetime movie
quality doesn't matter here the fans eat
up whatever we give them
sorry nothing is easy for us omaha
everyone ready swamp cast now small
birds and rollins okay so this is
actually like a conspiracy right
[Music]
stupid playoff picture sierra and i take
better photos several million times a
day you think you're the only
disgruntled athlete who the hell are you
i'm claiming and i'm here to talk to you
about the delaware claims
[Music]
you